سعاده ابراهيم بودرباله رئيس البرلمان
التونسي هو ضيفي في هذه الحلقه في البعد
الاخر اهلا بك معنا تقريبا ثلاثه شهور مضت
على بدء اعمال البرلمان الجديد الذي
تتراسونه كيف بتقيم لي هذه الفتره حتى
الان
احنا تسلمنا المهام يوم 13 مارس الفرد
وشرعنا في اعداد النظام الداخلي ثم تركيز
هياكل المجلس من مكتب مجلس واللجان والان
شارعنا في دراسه القوانين وبالتالي يعني
يعتبر تركيز الهياكل في وقت قياسي وبدايه
من هذا الاسبوع سوف نشرع
عده قوانين على اللجان ذات العلاقه وسوف
يجتمع المجلس في جلسه هذا الاسبوع لدراسه
احد احد المشاريع القوانين وبالتالي يعني
السير المجلس
بصوره عاديه
بس احنا بنعرف انه بعد
تنصيب المجلس عاده الصلاحيات التشريعيه
للبرلمان بس مع ذلك الصوره العامه اللي
بتنطبع لدى اطراف خارجيه واحيانا لدى
اطراف داخليه انه الجانب التشريعي ما زال
بيد البلاد هل هي مغالطه ام انه ما زالت
تونس تعيش تحت الاجراءات الاستثنائيه هل
البرلمان هو من من بيده الجانب التشريعي
ام انه ما زال بيد الرئيس
اكيد هي مغالطه باعتبار ان صلاحيه
التشريعيه تحولت للبرلمان منذ يوم 13 مارس
ومنذ يوم 13 مارس لم يصدر اي مرسوم عن
رئيس الجمهوريه
انتظرنا طوال هذه المده
وحاله السيد رئيس الجمهوريه المشاريع
القوانين على المجلس ونحن الان على تم
الاستعداد
لدراستها واحالتها على الجلسه العامه
للتصديق عليها
انجاز مهم قام به المجلس حتى اليوم صحيح
الفتره قصيره ولكن كثر يترقبون ما الذي
يمكن ان ينتج عن من قرارات عن هذا
البرلمان
هو اكبر تحدي لهذا المجلس هو استرداد ثقه
الشعب في العمل البرلماني لانه لا يخفى
على عليكم وان اعمال البرلمان الفارط نظرا
للاحداث التي مرت به جعل العمل البرلماني
يعني
يكون محل صوره سلبيه لدى المواطن التونسي
وبالتالي لنها تحدي هام هو ارجاع يعني
المصداقيه للعمل البرلماني
ونعتقد اننا يعني الان سائرون في الطريق
الصحيح وبالتالي اهم انجاز هو انه بعد
يعني استقرار المسار السياسي
نهتم بمشاريع القوانين ذات الطابع
الاقتصادي لكي
تدور العزل الاقتصاديه نحو نحو
الناحيه الايجابيه وعندما يعني تدور العجل
الاقتصاديه نحو الناحيه الايجابيه سيكون
لها تاثير على المسار الاجتماعي